alors question j'avais pas dire de fond
enfin question de l'air du temps quand
vous vous défendez françois fillon quand
vous prenez quelques distances été le
cas avec un livre d'abord puis dans le
fameux documentaire de franz olivier
giesbert qu'on a vu la semaine dernière
à l'égard de nicolas sarkozy des
distances prises donc mauvais drh et si
vous lui rendez hommage sur la politique
étrangère c'est vrai sur certains autres
aspects vous contestez ce qu'il a fait
tout ça vous vos des attaques d'une
violence incroyable de ceux qui sont
proches de nicolas sarkozy pourquoi je
crois qu'il faut que mes amis
comprennent que j'ai changé de vie je
fais une analyse politique qui est une
analyse politique lucide bienveillante
sur certains plans plus réservé sur
d'autres nicolas sarkozy c'est pas une
icône dans une niche c'est pas la vierge
marie dans la grotte de massabielle
devant lequel on s'agenouille mes amis
politiques que c'est différent ils sont
encore dans leur carrière politique il
ya ceux qui ont peur qu'il refusa ils
ceux qui espèrent le retour de nicolas
sarkozy se disant il faut pas insulter
l'avenir
si on veut avoir un poste et puis il ya
ceux qui souhaitent qu'ils ne reviennent
pas et qui tente de récupérer son
héritage
donc ça fait beaucoup de monde qui a
intérêt à me critiquer même si vous
qualifie de clown
oui il ya des mots qui sont extrêmement
violent il ya des mots qui sont
extrêmement violent qui sont oeil heures
tout à fait étonnant ya peut-être aussi
un petit poule machisme derrière tout
cela parce que je remarque que ce cet
inventaire cette analyse je ne suis pas
la seule à faire
alain juppé jean pierre raffarin
françois fillon bruno le maire le fond
mais je pense que pour ces gens là sont
dont une femme n'est-elle qu'un droit
c'est de se taire et de jouer les rôles
de groupies ça n'a jamais été mon cas